de gouverner les peuples du Royaume-Uni
de Grande-Bretagne et d'Irlande du Nord
aux autres royaumes et les territoires
qui sont attachés
coutume respective
Jean-Luc Mélenchon voilà ce qu'il a dit
tandis que dégouline à la télévision les
Siros dégoûtants de la monarchie tant de
monde vit dans la misère devant un
peuple qui a été si humilié par les
politiques néolibérales plus cher le 3
se voit remettre les insignes royaux
dont l'épée sertit de pierre précieuse
ce cinéma avec cet homme couvert de
déguisements de bijoux et de pierres
précieuses à quelque chose dès que
l'archevêque de kanterbury dépose
ensuite la couronne de Saint-Édouard sur
la tête du nouveau roi
la reine Kamila est couronné à son tour
avant que le couple royal ne quitte
Westminster je traînes respectueux de la
monarchie britannique et des
institutions britanniques mais je vais
pas vous mentir je n'y porte pas un
intérêt majeur donc je n'ai pas regardé
le couronnement un millier de personnes
réunies près de Rouen dans une ambiance
plutôt festive hier pour dénoncer le
projet de contournement autoroutier de
la ville regardez encore la semaine
dernière la Une de Valeurs Actuelles
voilà vous avez mixité forcée propagande
qui stabilisation tout ça le ministre de
la destruction nationale vous savez une
autoroute qui serait construite avec des
millions d'argent public qui coûteraient
6 euros pour 40 km ce qui est quand même
incroyable et bien nous sommes là en
nombre pour pouvoir les bloquer et leur
dire que ni ici ni ailleurs nous ne
voulons de nouvelles autoroutes qui ne
correspondent à rien à part au profit
des concessionnaires autoroutiers être
attaqué par l'extrême droite l'extrême
droite elle a une longue histoire de
presse de gringuard jusqu'à valeurs
actuelles c'est plutôt pour moi
ça c'est pour moi un sujet de fierté
Emmanuel Macron lui se rendra à Lyon
demain vous parliez de poursuivre d'une
certaine façon le combat commémoration
du 8 mai et des 80 ans de la mort de
Jean Moulin Jean Moulin n'aurait pas
interdit des manifestations avec des
bruits de casseroles par exemple donc on
est dans cette situation et justement
demain il y a à Lyon des appels à
manifester des appels à des casseroles
est-ce que vous vous souvenez ces appels
c'est pas que nous les soutenons c'est
que nous les comprenons vous prendriez
cette phrase oui tout à fait il n'aurait
pas interdit toute manifestation
d'ailleurs et c'est la démocratie qui
veut qu'on puisse s'exprimer
la mémoire de Jean Moulin près du fort
de Montluc c'est inacceptable c'est
inacceptable quand on veut croire aux
valeurs de la République les sons Jean
Moulin là où il est c'est-à-dire dans le
panthéon notre histoire nationale un
homme d'un courage extrême il y a dans
l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée nationale
certains parlementaires qui visent et
qui dont l'objectif est d'installer le
chaos et de faire en sorte que notre
institution ne fonctionne pas ne parlons
pas à sa place la réalité c'est que le 8
mai 1945 c'est un moment d'union
national et ça doit rester un moment
d'union nationale c'est un projet
politique qui est de dire nous nous
souhaitons instaurer une sixième
république nous considérons que la
Cinquième République elle est
complètement défaillante et donc nous en
faisons la démonstration dans les
missiles et nous légitimons notre projet
politique et bien oui je trouve que
c'est dangereux hier après-midi beaucoup
d'habitants profitent de ce samedi pour
faire leurs achats du weekend quand
soudain des coups de feu retentissent
les clients se réfugient derrière des
voitures
d'autres tentent de fuir
le policier a entendu les tirs il s'est
rendu à l'endroit des coups de feu à
fait face au suspect il a neutralisé des
milliers d'automobilistes fuient la
ville de drighton Valley au sud-ouest de
l'Alberta l'ordre des Baku a été donné
en pleine nuit lorsque les flammes ont
atteint les portes des maisons à plus
grande échelle vu de ce satellite voici
les départs de feu depuis 48 heures au
nord-ouest d'ennemonton
du jamais vu ici
quatre jours que cette province de
l'Ouest canadien est dévorée par les
flammes 25000 personnes ont déjà dû fuir
leur domicile obligé parfois de rouler
au milieu des brasiers